Let me introduce to you
a concept of a bundle of rays.
Okay, basically, again, remember,
what we are interested in is
rays of light that we want
to capture in a camera.
Bundle of rays basically implies is
that, at any point in a scene, basically
it's a concentric set of rays of light
hitting that scene or this point.
So in essence all rays of light as
converging to this specific point.
In my world of course
what I have is a camera.
At this point I can now
do a variety of things.
I can actually rotate this
camera just at one point.
So we can generalize this motion
by this curved arrow here.
So what I mean by a bundle of rays
basically now is nothing else, but
at this point, we are going to get
a concentric set of arrays of light.
And here I've just put them equidistant.
We just kind of show that all light
is converging at this point here.
And what I did by rotating
the camera at this point was try to
capture all of them.
Of course, you know, these rays of light
could be coming in all directions.
Let's now look at a specific type of
views to help us understand this.
For example, this is my first view.
I have a subject here and
I basically use the camera here.
And basically now I get these bundle
of rays coming into my camera.
Of course,
I could also have another view.
Right?
The camera was pointing this way.
This is my view.
This is my normal from both sides here.
And I now have two views.
So now question comes up is,
if I have these two views can I create
a synthetic wheel that basically
is in between both of them,
which exactly does have the same
points that I have here?
So this point here is also
visible in this image here.
And these points are also visible here.
So by just combining these two can I now
generate a new view, a synthetic view?
So the belief is that it's possible
to generate any synthetic view
of a camera as long as it has
some center of projection.
This one.
So as long as I keep my camera
at this center of projection and
if I do get this view and that view,
I can synthesize this one.
And this is something that's
important to note and
that's one of the reasons when we
talk about panoramas we want to
actually rotate them
around one single point.
Either actually have them
have a path like this or
just at this point rotate
our camera like this.